[Music]
so this is what I would this is what I
would say this is what I would suggest
is to to first I mean to first start
with the the let's say the intellectual
tradition that you come from and to
explore that to explore to read the
church fathers and to read the saints to
read the Mystics especially I would say
and to get a sense of what these things
mean once you get a sense of what these
things mean one of the things that that
we need to understand and I think that
that's been difficult for people to
understand is that the church let's say
is for everybody
the church is not for the yeah it is
actually molten now I shouldn't say that
the church is is for everybody it's for
the peasant the illiterate peasant as
much as it is for the the you know the
doctor of philosophy or the doctor of
theology and so because of that what you
encounter you have to be able to you you
you're the one who has to be able to
take what you hear and bring it to the
level that you can understand it right
you you can't and one and one of the
things that helps for me at least is is
liturgy and so liturgy doesn't depend on
your stupid you know priest doesn't
depend on your brilliant priest it
depends on an entire a process of
thousands of years of refining and and
and bringing together all these elements
and so when you let's say is if you go
to I would say like if you if you go to
- to a Catholic Church I would say if or
if you come from a Catholic background I
would say look for those Catholic
churches that have liturgy and you will
you will find a treasure like a treasure
trove in there like you you have no idea
how amazing
which you can find there I mean
obviously like I I would say like
ultimately I would say become Orthodox
but that's kind of might be might be 2 e
2 2 2 2 facile ax I think to say that
but it's there like everything it's it's
it's really uh what's what's in the
liturgy and when you hear the songs
being read or when you you you you
participate in that process I mean it is
as deep as anything you'll ever
encounter and then what happens is that
you you can become a part of that
community coming coming to something
else because the church is is Aust like
it's that's nothing else it's like if if
the intellectual class if we abandon the
body let's say if we abandoned the
community what's going to happen I mean
it's going to get worse and worse and
worse but if we like if we if we dive in
and we say like okay I am surrounded by
really campy or silly or superstitious
ideas and it's like whatever you know
that that's fine I know the core of this
like i I've been touched by the core of
this thing and then we can be agents of
transformation that's what I think but
also you'll be surprised you'd be really
surprised at like the the the you meet
some some literalist some you know
person who has the in craziest ideas of
what of what these stores mean or it has
has really really silly ideas but if you
look at their life and if you look at
how they raise their family and if you
look at at how honorable they are and
how you know and how they're the pillars
of their community then you kind of you
you realize that your intellectual
capacity has to take a bit of a human a
human beating a little bit it's true and
you just kind of say okay these are some
awesome people here yeah like you know
they they might not understand abstract
things but like their lives are just
amazing you know and there they they
haven't haven't lost themselves to to
you know to entertainment or to
pornography or to you know they're
they're upstanding and they and they
they you know they are holding the world
together so and they're not swinging
back and forth between those poles of
chaos and order that we were talking
sack like that silent uncle you know
who's just like they're you know and and
doesn't necessarily go off you know one
way or the other like those people
they're the ones holding the world
together you know like you just kind of
have this common sense you know and it's
it's not even thought out sometimes it's
just this intuitive common sense which
just comes from bathing in in a somewhat
traditional world you know they're the
ones who are stopping could they're
there they're the secret bulwark of the
world yeah I mean it's it's I think you
might be on I think you might be right I
mean I you know when I hear that
immediately I want to go like no no
that's that can't be true because I
think I have so much wrapped up in that
not being true you know I like spend so
much money on my college education I've
traveled like I was raised to be a one
of these to be a modern secular citizen
you know and when I hear you say
something like that I it it it I'm
triggered John yeah I need like here's
that here's a path like this is the path
that I can trace and and I and I think
like I would want I wanted to make a
video about this but I can lay it out
for you here okay you know you're you
grow up you you you are you you're 13
years old and you have this really
simplistic kind of naive way of seeing
the world and understanding religion
understanding the Bible understanding
all these things then you become a
teenager you go to college and you're
you know you're especially to go to
liberal arts college you know your
philosophy teachers demolish you let
they just demolish everything and then
you you question everything then
hopefully like what you're going through
you realize oh wait a minute maybe
there's more there than what I thought
then you look at the idea let's say you
look at God and you're sad no wait a
minute no one that had intellectual
maybe my my you know my aunt who dropped
out of school you know she thinks God is
a is like a basically an invisible man
on a cloud maybe but that's not what
Christianity has ever been in its
highest form so then you you you get
that and you understand this idea of a
hierarchy of being and the idea of the
infinite and the idea of this process of
logos all of that it's like you you
start to see it and you start to live
and you start to understand it and then
you then the last to me the last step in
that is then to come back and say you
know our Father who is in heaven and not
have a single shred of problem with
saying that yeah and then facing that
smug like New York liberal and then they
look at you with this sneer when you say
our God who is in heaven and it's like
you know exactly what you went through
and everything you had the punishment
you gave yourself to get to that and all
you can do in your deep deep deep deep
down self is just smile and just go
that's fine man but that's totally fine
because I know I know exactly why I'm
here like I know exactly why I say my
father who is our Father who is in
heaven I have no issue with it and so
it's like you it's I mean I like it
anyways for me it's actually become a
joy like yeah to to just sit there and
then see that contempt in someone's eyes
and just just be like you know what I'm
okay with it I know where I am like I
know I'm not sure you know where you are
I know exactly where I am well it's wow
I think you should definitely make a
video about that I mean it's that is
really I I mean I appreciate you walking
me through that it's really a beautiful
it's a beautiful description um
and it's also and I feel less triggered
now so thanks if you enjoyed this
content in our exploration of symbolism
get involved I love to read your
comments in the comment section below
please go ahead and share this on social
media to all your friends and also
please consider supporting us
financially on patreon you'll find the
link to the patreon page in the
description below